I can't remember I don't want to
remember what I was like before Gwen
actually he did say he doesn't remember
life before you are your eyes watery yes
Blake saved my life everybody knows that
the couple of four years have a new duet
together called nobody but you judging
by the lyrics it's not a matter of if
you'll put a ring on it
just when Wanda who you marry to you're
not helping the rumors
I love the rumors oh my god who wouldn't
want to be married to win Stefani
lucky me oh my god of course JLo and
a-rod made the list I love you papi
the two got engaged in March and JLo has
given et all their I do details so far
Alex did give a hint he's gonna be a
long flight said it's gonna be a long
flight yeah I know he we don't know yet
so he's just saying we can narrow it
down yet Nick Jonas and his wife of one
year Priyanka Chopra are next on our
list we're just chillin at home as he
tending to he's the he's a planner okay
he's just better at it so I'll do it
[Music]
Micke taking charge is how they started
dating he said into my DMS yeah what
kind of game are any lines was he
spitting out he was just like I think
you're beautiful and we need to hang and
I was like that's direct it was kind of
an instant thing new once we locked in
together that I've got I had a partner
for life or the teammates and I can walk
to the good times the bad times with and
that was times the key I'm blushing now
sterling K Brown and his wife of 12
years Ryan Michele bath they showed et
just how picture-perfect they are the
busy working parents of two told me how
they balance it all
oh I keep telling people everybody uses
that word balance but I was like that is
in myth it's whack-a-mole one day at a
time one day at a time
yes I mean that's the real truth I mean
we have a lot of people who help us out
and we're always trying to coordinate
schedules to the best of our ability
another cute couple that keeps it real
on et pink and husband carry hard you
guys have your 14 year anniversary
coming up oh poor Dinah he deserves a
trophy it's been a while how do we use
to make a big deal out of it now we're
just lucky to be together here's some
more love in 2020 and beyond
[Music]